this video is sponsored by squarespace
what's going on people today we're about
to explore the evidence behind how
attack on titan could actually have an
anime original ending for a bit of
context here when the final chapter of
the manga was released it led to a
massive reaction online with one side of
the fanbase being happy with how things
ended while the other side didn't
exactly feel the same way if you follow
my channel you'll know that i thought
the ending was mostly good however i
could also acknowledge there were
certain plot points that could have been
wrapped up in a more satisfying way for
many people though their disappointment
with the finale became so much that
eventually tons of theories started
being posted about how the anime would
break away from the manga to create a
brand new ending the events of this new
ending will vary depending on which
theory you happen to look at but usually
aaron is nearly always the father of
historia's baby and he completes a
full-scale rumbling of the entire planet
having now read a few of these theories
myself i thought it would be fun to come
up with my own spin on the idea and the
aim of this video is to convince you
that an anime original ending could
hypothetically make sense regardless of
whether it ends up happening or not
before we get into it though this
channel is on the long road to 500k
subscribers and so i genuinely
appreciate it if you smash that sub
button if you haven't already
okay so the core of this theory relies
on there being at least four separate
timelines which are the original
timeline the manga timeline the lost
girls timeline and finally the anime
timeline in order to explain how all of
these universes are connected we first
need to examine the source of all living
matter also known as the weird creature
living inside aaron's spine this ancient
worm is the thing that gave humanity the
power of the titans and at its full
potential it literally has the ability
to bend reality itself what i mean by
that is that up until now the coordinate
has enabled aaron to see the future
influence the past and enter a dimension
that transcends time and space but what
you might not have realized is that its
true power is even more significant
during episode 19 of the final season
aaron experienced visions not just from
the past and the future but also from an
actual alternate timeline that exists in
the multiverse this glimpse of goth
mikasa and nerdy armin is from a
completely different reality in which
the main characters attend a modern day
high school in their universe titans
haven't existed for at least 100 years
and personally i never used to take this
timeline seriously until the anime made
it 110 canon for goth mikasa to appear
in aaron's memories in both episode 19
and the manga it proves beyond any doubt
that the source of all living matter is
connected to the multiverse this
connection is precisely what makes the
anime original ending possible with
mikasa being the trigger that causes new
universes to be created way back in 2013
a visual novel called lost girls
introduced us to the idea of multiple
realities in attack on titan and since
then it's been adapted into a comic
version and an anime version the story
takes place during season 1 after mikasa
finds out that erin was eaten by the
santa claus titan and in her grief she
experiences a vision from another
universe in this other reality a ton of
things were different but i guess the
main things we need to focus on for now
is that her parents were never killed by
kidnappers and her love for aaron was
just as strong even without him having
to save her life by the time the vision
comes to an end mikasa questions whether
everything she just saw was really just
a dream with the novel implying that her
soul left her body and experienced
memories from another world the anime
adaptation takes things even further as
it basically confirms that mikasa's
grief is what leads to the creation of
these new branch timelines seemingly
whenever aaron dies meeks's emotions
becomes so intense that the source of
all living matter manifests a new
reality in these realities the
characters have a chance to try things
again differently and sometimes they
even remember fleeting memories from
their alternate selves this could
explain why has suffered from headaches
for a long time since the pain could be
a side effect of her memories being
viewed by alternate versions of herself
and alternate versions of ymir
moving on now that we've established the
multiverse as a thing it's time to break
down how the four main realities are
connected starting with the original
timeline as the name suggests this was
the very first timeline to exist and in
it mikasa confessed her true feelings
one important thing you need to remember
is that during the trip's liberio aaron
was seriously doubting whether he wanted
to go through with the rumbling that's
why he decided to ask microsoft why she
cares about him because depending on her
response he was willing to give up on
his plan to destroy the world in this
original timeline she gave him the
answer he wanted by telling him how she
really felt and following that they run
away together to live out his remaining
years in peace the house they were
living in was presumably built by the
attack titan and for the next four years
it seemed like most of their days were
spent either relaxing fishing or
collecting wood gradually though the
time came when the curse of emir began
to destroy aaron's body which is what
happens to every titan shifter once
they've had the power for too long
knowing that his death was unavoidable
aaron made mikasa promise to move on
after he dies and it's why she doesn't
cry when he eventually passes away even
though she was devastated on the inside
she puts her on a brave face so that he
doesn't know how much she's grieving
hence why her final words to him would
just see you later meeks's extreme pain
in this moment is what causes the
founder to manifest a new branch
timeline and this reality is the version
we see in the manga for anyone watching
who hasn't read chapter 1 early on it
shows aaron having a dream in which
mikasa says to him see you later just
like how she did at the end of his first
life the dream then goes black which
symbolizes his death and then he wakes
up under a tree in a similar position to
how he was when he died this is all
meant to show that the manga is the
start of a brand new reality and when he
wakes up he even asks me because so why
her hair has gone on so long because
he's comparing it to their time in the
mountains what this proves is that deep
inside a person's mind they can remember
emotions they felt from an alternate
reality and these emotions can then
cause them to make different decisions
for instance when aaron asks mikasa how
she feels in the manga timeline she
hesitates to answer the question and
then goes on to give him the one answer
that he didn't want the reason she did
this is because subconsciously she
remembers that confessing her love last
time is what led to his eventual death
and so she chooses to answer another way
in the hope that somehow aaron might be
saved if they do things differently of
course things did end up differently but
not in the way that she wanted with
everything coming to a climax in chapter
138
in that chapter aaron had wiped out 80
percent of the world's population and by
this point it was clear the only way to
stop him was to kill him the extreme
stress of the situation caused her to
have a blistering headache and while her
head was starving she tearfully thinks
how she wants to go back to their home
as she says this the chapter flashes
back to their previous life in the
original timeline showing that under the
right circumstances mikasa can vividly
remember memories from other realities
in particular she remembers the moment
when aaron asked her to forget about him
after his death but in the present day
of the manga timeline she just doesn't
have the strength to actually do it
three years later a still devastating
mikasa sits beside his grave and it's
clear that she still hasn't gotten over
the fact that he's not going to be
coming back in case you've never seen
this panel before aaron's decapitated
head is buried beneath the same tree
from chapter one and since mikasa hasn't
gotten over him her emotions trigger the
creation of another branch timeline
where eren violently wakes up in the
same spot notice how in this new
timeline he doesn't peacefully awaken
like before but instead the anime
focuses purely on his head referencing
the fact that this is where his head was
buried in the previous reality on top of
that his dream is also now completely
different because rather than witnessing
a vision of mikasa saying see you later
he now sees memories from the future of
his mother being eaten titans invading
the walls and perhaps most importantly
he sees kids toys inside a royal looking
bedroom this was arguably the first
major hint towards an anime original
ending since why else would aaron see a
vision of children's toys unless those
toys belong to a child that he has some
kind of connection to in episode 28 of
the final season historian asks aaron
what he thinks about her becoming
pregnant and this moment was super
important if she hadn't gotten pregnant
then the military police would have
killed zeke long before the jager bros
were able to make contact so to put it
simply historia's baby is what enabled
the rumbling to happen that's why it's
entirely feasible that erin could be the
father because historia having this baby
is something that benefits his own goals
the memory of these toys are just
further indication that this might be
the case and what's crazier is that it
might not be the only memory that
deviates from the manga as an example we
know that when aaron kisses story his
hand he saw his own future through the
eyes of grisha but the audience never
gets to see that future for ourselves
for all we know anime aaron could have
seen a future in which he wipes out 100
of humanity which is a huge difference
to manga aaron who allowed the alliance
to stop him before it got to that point
what if in this anime timeline his
subconscious mind remembers the regret
he felt the last time around and chooses
to go down a different path where he can
survive and be with his friends if this
is the case then it would mean the
ending of the anime will drastically
divert from the manga and in a minute
i'm going to explain what aaron would
have to do before we continue though
it's worth highlighting the importance
of the lost girls timeline as i
mentioned earlier this reality is the
one that mikasa created after she
thought aaron had been killed in trust
and the reason it matters is because it
demonstrates that even in a perfect
world there's nothing that can save him
from death to summarize the plot points
that i haven't talked about already in
this timeline the warriors never
breached the wall most likely because
they decided to return home after marcel
got eaten this meant that most of
humanity inside the walls continued to
believe that the survey corps were
useless and eventually this leads to
them getting shut down by the royal
government in this reality mikasa had
already told erin that she didn't like
the idea of from joining the scouts so
now that they don't exist anymore you'd
expect that the two of them could now
have a peaceful life on the island
however aaron being aaron his desire for
freedom was so intense that he and armin
spent months planning how they would
escape to the outside in the manga
version the two of them were fixing up a
small airplane that was left behind by
armin's parents but in the anime version
they were working on a hot air balloon
to lift them over wall maria
unfortunately in both scenarios the
vehicle slamming to the wall killing
aaron in the process and the moral of
the story was that no matter how many
worlds mikasa creates she'll never be
able to save his life in every universe
he'll seemingly always die regardless of
whether he has titan powers or not so
the question then becomes could the
anime original ending be the one
exception for the purpose of this video
the answer to that question is maybe
although as we're about to see things
would need to change pretty drastically
for that to happen
first off we have to assume that aaron
and the anime did in fact see different
future memories and from that point
onwards he would have known things that
no other version of the character was
aware of information like that would
then enable him to make different
choices when it comes to the final
season and there's one particular moment
we need to focus on during the final
battle zeke tries to help the alliance
by revealing himself to levi and without
hesitation the captain swoops in to
decapitate the beast titan by killing
zeke the rumbling then immediately comes
to a stop since aaron needed to maintain
contact with the titan of royal blood
meanwhile at the exact same time this
was all going on back on parodies
historia was shown to be giving birth it
was established in season three that
newborn albion babies can inherit the
power of a titan shifter but only if
that shifter dies without passing down
their abilities given that zeke died
without passing down the beast titan and
given that historia was going through
labour at the same time the story is
literally spelling it out for us that
her royal bloody baby inherited his
titan on a personal level this is
something i've been talking about ever
since the day zeke's death was first
confirmed and i thought it was wasted
potential that such an interesting plot
point never ended up affecting the
finale for that reason in an anime
original ending it'd be interesting to
see aaron using this royal baby to
reactivate the rumbling and there's one
realistic way it can happen if we flash
back to when the jager bros first made
contact there was a good five to ten
seconds where a huge lightning bolt
shoots down into shiganchina during that
moment eric had done the same thing as
lara tiber and essentially used the
lightning as a conduit to send himself
on the ground while underground he could
then encase himself in a crystal in
exactly the same way she did and he
could stay in this position until his
body fully regenerates on top of that he
could then remotely control his massive
titan on the surface by using the
warhammer cable and remember since this
cable is made from titan hardening the
founder can keep extending it for
literally as long as he needs to it's
highly unlikely that anyone in
shiganshin would even notice if he did
this considering they'd be too
distracted by the falling debris pure
titans and politics giving aaron all the
time he needs to put things in place as
the founder he could easily control one
of zeke's titans and make them bring his
crystal near to historia's location and
at that point he just needs to sit back
and wait for things to play out days
later when levi eventually beheads the
beast's titan and brings the rumbling to
a stop that would be aaron's signal to
exit his shell and make contact with the
royal baby this fresh contact with the
titan of royal blood would once again
give him access to the coordinate and i
reckon there are two main things he'd
want to do number one the colossal
titans would begin marching forward
again as he restarts the rumbling and
number two he'd bring his friends into
pass to explain the situation aaron
would have to make it super clear that
although he gave him the freedom to try
and stop him in this reality there's
nothing left they can do to actually win
that's why he'd offer everyone in the
alliance the chance to return to the
island where they can continue their
lives or even start a whole new life
without the fear of being hunted down by
mali
over the next couple days a hundred
percent of the world's population would
then be eradicated leaving a planet
where only the alien empire exists mass
murder on this scale is something the
alliance obviously wanted to avoid but
for the people on the island they'd be
on the side of the egress and would
worship aaron is the closest thing they
have to a god from a purely political
standpoint i think most people would
want him to become the new ruler of
elder which is something flock outright
stated during the final season however
aaron has never had that kind of
ambition and instead i think his main
focus would be rebuilding his broken
relationships this is what brings us to
how the titan curse would come to an end
in the anime original timeline because
if aaron is going to survive in this
universe the curse has to disappear one
way or another if we examine the manga
timeline for a sec the reason time
powers seemingly disappeared wasn't just
because aaron was killed but rather it
was because aaron was killed by mikasel
while the founder was watching his death
under those specific circumstances is
what ended the curse of emir cause ymir
saw that mikasa was able to let the
person she loves die something the
founder herself was never able to do in
yamir's mind the concept of love was
intertwined with the idea of her being a
slave and fritz being the master meaning
she always did what he wanted even if
that meant making titans for two
thousand years however by mikasa being
able to kill the man she loved ymir
learnt that breaking free from her slave
mindset is possible and that was the
true cause of the titan curse
disappearing therefore for the tying
curse to disappear in the anime timeline
it's crucial that ymir learns this same
lesson but without someone having to
kill aaron the way i see it there's very
few ways that can happen especially
considering that mikasa still loves him
regardless of whether he's a mass
murderer bearing that in mind there's
almost nothing aaron could do that would
make mikasa willingly turn her back on
him which is i guess what would have to
happen in this timeline for the founder
to find peace however after thinking
about it for a while i did come up with
one controversial thing that has the
potential to make this a reality and
that's if aaron is really the father of
historia's baby if something like that
was to be confirmed it might just be
enough to force mikisa to move on
because she feel betrayed on like a
million different levels when it comes
to emir she often saw fritz with other
women and it's heavily implied she never
had the courage to do or say anything
about it so if mikasa was to react by
leaving aaron forever then amazingly
that could be enough to eradicate the
power of the titans ultimately the only
way to remove the curse of emir is for
your mere spirit to be at peace and if
the only way she can find peace is by
learning these lessons through mikasa
then this is the way it has to be
honestly i do wish there was a better
way that time powers could disappear but
based on the ending we got in the manga
this was the most logical method that
didn't involve eren dying or mikasa
dying of course a sad consequence would
be that the original trio would be split
up forever with armin being like a
parent who has custody of mikasa during
the week and then custody of aaron every
other weekend anyhow people that was my
take on how an anime original ending
could theoretically make sense and if
you liked it then i'd appreciate if you
hit that like button and subscribe for
more videos like this
before we end today's video i wanted to
give a huge shout out to today's sponsor
squarespace thanks to squarespace i
recently began designing my own website
which is going to be a place where i'll
be uploading articles blog posts and
other cool stuff related to the channel
as someone without any experience at
building websites it usually would have
been impossible for me to build
something like this without help but
thanks to the dozens of easy to use
templates the whole process became super
easy to understand if you've ever
thought about starting a blog or website
of your own then i recommend heading
over to
squarespace.comwork where you'll have
access to a two-week free trial and when
you're finally ready to launch you'll
save 10 of your first purchase of a
domain thanks again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video and the link is in
the description for anyone who wants to
get started